what's going on guys
we have a very special guest two special
guests so why don't we just introduce
everybody and get right to it first you
know him as bran Stark on Game of
Thrones he's also one of the voice stars
from the upcoming the boxtrolls Isaac
Hempstead right Isaac thanks for being
here and you've seen her all over your
TV she's an actress and a comedian and a
huge game Thrones fan Milan 'vine Trump
I'm Ilana hi how so you have a big movie
opening up here in America the boxtrolls
yeah it's based on a children's book I
think it's actually collection stories
by a writer called Allan snow and then
some of these fantastical you know
children's fantasy books very different
Game of Thrones fan yeah in case you are
wondering are you you won't expect any
beheadings or murders or sexify and the
boxtrolls I'm sorry to disappoint you
all but it sounds like such a sweet
story to come from the mind of Jon Snow
oh no I'm a louse no Alan Snow the
exterminator is voiced by Ben Kingsley
one of our great actors what did sir Ben
smell like hmm pink fluffy unicorn
Oh spaghetti uh mixed with sort of
cotton candy that's and with a guy
that's nothing she's got nothing short
of magical let's shift gears and talk
about Game of Thrones where you live in
England how big is Game of Thrones over
there it's big in in Britain but uh is
you know certainly not as big over here
and I look pretty different from her
from Brandon Stark
yeah your hair is shorter you're tall
tall are you wikipedia says I'm five for
eight so I'll go with that
okay nothing's ever wrong and look at me
yeah I make all my biographical
information from Wikipedia
what's Hodor like in real life we have
the best fun on set I'm always there on
his back singing spongebob songs - hey
Laura does he ever get sick of carrying
you yes I think so no you're like you're
fighting Freddy food I'll be carrying
Hodor you know the brighter Oliver
you're one of my favorite parts of the
show is when when you go all warge mmm
and oh I must go kill the Lannisters
did you learn to do that for the show or
did they know that could do that I used
to watch wrestling and I remember the
Undertaker always used to do that so I
took my my lessons that's amazing
real well no I didn't really go and say
hey undertake you know I know
yeah yeah on the show you can't walk in
real life you can mmm would you call
that lying or acting lying okay thank
you
so since your movie the boxtrolls is
based on a children's book we thought
wouldn't it be cool if there were Game
of Thrones children's books so we came
up with a bunch of titles this is Game
of Thrones children's books mommy
Amaya bastard the Jon Snow story you
know there are a lot of single-parent
households out there probably the only
way that a mother could explain to her
child why he or she is a bastard what
about I love my brother by Cersei Lana
yeah I'm not sure if the message that is
gonna be put over in that book is an
entirely savoury one instead of where
the wild things are where the wildlings
are that should be a spin-off show Yeah
right
just yeah just hanging out with wild yes
well what do you think we'd see the
wildlings do on a day to day not wash
not wash yeah definitely not wash good
night moon door what do you think would
happen in good night moon door it would
just be a baby pun good night moon oh
you fell down
yeah just a baby falling through a moon
door yeah have you ever seen that moon
door oh so you're gonna stab you have a
thing oh I've ever seen a baby fall
through a moon door I haven't actually
oh you are missing out it's adorable
it's it mommy I control the wolf fan
with words
I've already started petting it
I'm halfway through the first drop so
you can expect it on Charles pretty soon
everyone needs to work out what you
can't working out maybe you know if you
go that I like that it's a one game of
Thrones yeah I just walk out man
How to Train Your Dragon I mean you
could even have dragon and it would
still make sense
yeah well make it sense take it all the
all the kids of Westeros who have
obviously seen that for a big fans of it
I realize there were movie theaters in
Westeros oh yeah yeah I think if there's
a good one is a multiplex in King's
Landing oh yeah Wow I think that's where
the most folks actually originate oh I
heard there's a really a big AMC north
of the wall yeah yeah it's definitely
got 20 Plex not many people good Game of
Thrones a reality show there yeah it's
it's kind of like big brother
oh good you have a oh yeah okay but
unfortunately yeah encyclopedia brand
bran would be like a kid detective
solving little crimes around Westeros
yeah I know so my soul gets encyclopedia
Brant war yeah mm-hmm he would just find
out right away though you would just
warg into the sword
how could you warg into a sword I would
be pushing it a little bit but uh okay
I'll consult my encyclopedia what's
after that one encyclopedia bran I think
that would be a more violent detective
show so I think there's a lot of like
potential to take Game of Thrones into
other places like what about cereals the
obvious ones gotta be brands like brand
play run stuff likes the ultimate place
to take it would be a Saturday morning
kids show and you could lend your voice
talent to it because you're a talented
voice actor as evidenced by the upcoming
film the boxtrolls opening September 26
check it out I want to thank my guest
Isaac Hempstead right thank you for
being here
a lot of vine trouble thank you so what
Game of Thrones children's book would
you want to see leave us your ideas in
the comment section below
best answers we're going to send you a
screen junkies t-shirt again thanks to
this awesome panel and thank you for
watching I'm how run
I kept me up on Twitter by what you
think down Zilla beginning really fun
and then great in it but the boss battle
at the end was pretty also photos one of
those movies where I really liked it but
if somebody didn't like it on my aunt